Today's lottery hopefuls have another slim chance at becoming a multimillionaire.
Tonight's Powerball jackpot drawing has jumped to at least 825 million dollars.
It's the second largest prize in Powerball history.
No one has matched all six numbers since August 3rd.
But, if you beat the one in 292 million odds of winning it all tonight,...
...you can get your millions spread over 29 years...
...or choose the cash out option which is worth an estimated 410 million dollars.
So, you're saying there's a chance?
There's always a chance if you play.
Would you share?
If we all pitch in.
How much do you want me to share?
A third.
A third?
You want me to give a third of the money?
If we all pitch in.
I don't know.